one of those bewilderingly everything
moves for example do you remember the
latest New York Times hit piece on Brett
Kavanaugh one were they found a brand
new accusation of sexual misconduct but
then later had to admit it was all a
sham when did that happen it feels like
about a year ago but actually no it was
just last week
that's the Trump Aran news cycle for you
scandals that used to go on for months
now seem to end in hours nothing
illustrates that better than this
bizarre Ukraine story that we're all
living through so a week ago no one had
even heard of it last night we're on the
brink of impeachment because of it and
now it seems to be over already just to
bring you back and remind you what just
happened the same angry news anchors who
brought you stormy Daniels and the
Russia hoax now wanted you to know that
big orange is days in the White House
were finally over why because Trump they
said threatened to withhold military aid
to Ukraine and it's essential that we
said military aid to Ukraine for some
reason but someone's gonna withhold it
unless they did something bad to Joe
Biden in his family basically it was an
extortion plot against Ukraine and
that's a crime the news anchor shattered
a crime
Trump was finished well this morning
they turned out to be wrong actual
evidence emerged and it contradicted
what they told us yesterday the
administration released a transcript of
the president's phone call with
ukrainian head of state and it's just
none of the things that news anchors
claimed it would show we did for
yourself don't trust us it's right
online try to find the extortion in
there
there isn't any Trump never even
mentions military aid well yes they're
saying now but he asked a foreign
government to investigate an American
citizen and that's immoral okay was it
immoral when three Democratic senators
wrote a letter to Ukraine just last year
demanding investigations into Trump no
answer on that question where they will
tell you if we hear back instead now
they're telling us that the transcript
of the phone call can't be real
it must be doctored watch Chuck Schumer
and Adams
spin their conspiracy theory last night
do you trust the White House enough to
take that transcript and believe that
that is an actual representation of what
transpired well you know I think sadly
it's the case as you described that we
cannot trust the administration with
respect to anything that it produces
simply to release the transcript is not
going to come close to ending the need
of the American public and the Congress
to see what actually happened so again
that was last night before the
transcript was publicly available now
that it is publicly available for Adam
chips
conspiracy addled brain has lurched into
a different direction now he's telling
us that the transcript one that he's
already denounced as fake is in fact
real but it doesn't show what it should
show which is to say it doesn't show the
president doing any of the things is
supposedly justifying impeachment why
well Adam Schiff explains because the
president like a Navajo code talker is
speaking in secret code this is how a
mafia boss talks what have you done for
us we've done so much for you but
there's not much reciprocity I have a
favor I want to ask you and what does
that favor of course the favor is to
investigate his political rival a
classic mafia like shakedown of a
foreign leader you know we're not
psychiatrist here but honestly Adams
ships in that case it's it's true it's
hard to believe he's in Congress poor
people of Anaheim or wherever he's from
Southern California the valley somewhere
it's hard to believe he's actually in
Congress he's actually a committee
chairman believe it or not too bad the
25th amendment doesn't apply to members
of Congress but to be fair most
Democrats are not anywhere near as crazy
as Adam Schiff not even the same
ballpark they're just very cynical
extremely cynical more cynical you've
ever thought of being for example watch
congressman Al Green who's not stupid or
crazy explain what's actually driving
impeachment watch this are you concerned
that impeachment talk may actually help
the president's reelection
I'm concerned that if we don't impeach
this president he will get reelected I'm
concerned if we don't impeach you will
get reelected I'm concerned that
democracy could happen we've got to stop
that it's about power duh you knew that
that's what it's always about
power nobody pushing for impeachment
actually cares about secret deals with
foreign leaders oh please
much less injustice or the truth again
these are the most cynical people in the
United States of America what they care
about and you knew this already was
winning the 2020 presidential election
that's all they care about getting their
mitts on the levers of power and
exercising power for its own sake that's
what drives them that's why they get up
in the morning Democratic leaders have
decided that impeaching Trump is
essential if they're going to win next
year
so they're staking everything on this
bizarre flimsy scandal that the rest of
us can barely even understand will at
work probably not if personal attacks on
Trump were effective if calling him a
racist or a traitor actually worked then
Hillary Clinton will be running for
re-election right about now who's not
gonna work this never works if you want
to beat Trump McKee make your case on
the issues he won on the issues make a
counter case the geniuses can't figure
that out in the end really the loser
here in this impeachment nonsense it's
likely to be Joe Biden Biden you'll
recall is the front-runner supposedly
he's supposed to be the safe choice the
guy who's gonna energize the Obama
coalition and win back the White House
and yet now Democrats have in effect
demanded that we spend the next six
months talking about Biden and his son's
alleged corruption because that's at the
core of this Ukraine story if we're
talking about Ukraine and impeachment
we're talking about Joe Biden's
corruption alleged corruption that can't
help his campaign for president in fact
it's likely to take it looks like
sabotage really they must have gamed
this out they must know is it sabotage
well honestly we don't know we're not in
the room maybe it is
or maybe Democrats have just peek
so obsessed with destroying Donald Trump
that they're destroying themselves
accidentally